Well, Dustin, Joshua,
congratulations gentlemen.
The two of you have made
it through the first two
rounds of this competition,
and boy was it a nail biter.
In this third and
final round, we're
going to send you back to
your home forges for four days
to build an iconic
weapon from history.
We want you to build this--
the Tuareg takoba.
The takoba is a
type of broadsword
that has been used by the
nomadic Tuareg people of North
Africa since the 14th century.
This double edged
lightweight blade was carried
for self-defense
on long journeys,
designed to deliver
lethal slashes and stabs
against a rival warrior.
Due to the Tuareg's
aversion to iron,
there is no exposed steel or
iron on the hilt of the sword,
so it cannot touch
the user's hand.
Measuring more
than a meter long,
this deadly weapon was
seen as a symbol of wealth.
Some members of the Takoba clan
still carry this weapon today.
Good luck, gentlemen.
We'll see you in four days.
My name is Dustin
Matheny I'm 36 years old.
I'm from Glasgow, Montana.
Growing up, I've always
loved knives and swords.
Then I watched "Forged in Fire."
And you see it and you're like,
I think I can maybe do that.
So I'm half an inch over.
I'm happy with that.
It'll be good.
I got my blade heat treated.
Here we go.
Move on to the pommel now.
I'm going to try to key
out the bottom of this
so that fits straight,
and then I'll
just have like a pommel
nut that goes on top
and holds everything together.
Whether or not it
works, we'll see.
So I got my handle all together.
I have the handle
all the epoxied.
Everything is good.
The nut's tight.
Guards on these takobas, they
have stars and all other types
of geometric shapes, and
I had hat pins that I
put in some of my knives.
Definitely not a cowboy,
but my brother passed away
10 years ago and he was, so I
think I'll throw this in there
for him.
Start to Dremel them out to kind
of recess them into the handle.
Not bad.
Fairly happy with it.
I am worried about the tang.
I do wish I would have made
the tang a little bit thicker,
but I mean, it's
out of my hands now.
My name is Joshua Kim.
I'm 22 years old.
I live in the Golden State
California, San Pedro.
I started off bladesmithing
in middle school.
It was something
in its rawest form,
so simple, yet so abstract.
And all you have
to limit yourself
as a bladesmith is
your own imagination,
and that's what I love about it.
Now we're getting somewhere.
It's getting to the length.
Pretty darn big, so
right now my main concern
is to make that skinny.
Never done a fuller before.
It was a little like
your first love, almost.
Time for the fun part.
It's time to quench my blade.
I'm scared by the
hardening process.
If that fails, I just have a
giant, oversized butter knife.
Quench it, but I see bend in it.
Not happy with that.
I'll go for a second time.
I know a lot of people that go
into the quench multiple times,
they have a lot of stress
fractures and everything else.
If I mess up again, I don't
know what I'm going to do.
Golly, it's a little
warped on the side.
I'm not liking the
bend in my blade,
so I'm going to be
hardening it again.
Oh my gosh.
Yo, that is a good looking
blade, my man-- shoot.
I got six hours left.
All I got to do
is make a handle.
But what I'm going to
use, some good brass
as the top and bottom then put
some walnut, space of copper,
then a space of
purple heartwood,
then another piece of brass.
That is a guard.
For the handle construction,
I'll just use leather.
It's coming along quite nicely.
And at day four, I
finished this blader.
Well, golly-gee-willikers,
Someone
going to give me $10,000.
Wink wink, nudge,
nudge, please, please?
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Your Tuareg takobas
look beautiful,
but the kind of beauty I'm
looking for is the lethal kind.
I'm going to take your weapon,
deliver some lethal blows
in this ballistics dummy.
Dustin, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
[gooshing sound]
[hacking noise]
All right, Dustin, let's
talk about your weapon here.
First up, your
handle construction.
I like the ovoid feel of this.
The flare you have
there in your pommel
actually gives great
retention for this.
Your tip is sharp
enough to penetrate.
Your edges are sharp
when you're cutting out,
and you can wield this
to do that kind of damage
on this ballistics dummy.
Overall, sir, a weapon
like this, it will kill.
Awesome.
All right, Joshua, your turn.
You ready?
Keep everyone alive.
All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
[gooshing sound]
[hacking noise]
Dang.
All right.
Joshua, let's talk
about your weapon here.
Your pommel right here could
have used some weight to it.
But because it's forward
weighted and the fact
that you have a very sharp edge,
every slice, as you can see,
is very deep into
the ballistic dummy.
And more importantly, sir,
your weapon, it will kill.
Yeah!
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test--
our desert well chop.
Now, to test the strength
and overall construction
of your blades, I'll be
chopping into our well
house, as well as the well.
Dustin, you're on deck.
You ready?
I guess so.
OK. (LAUGHING)
[music playing]
[sword striking]
[clatter]
Agh!
All right.
We were doing so well
for a moment, there.
What actually happened was,
with insetting your blade down
into this piece of wood,
any of that leverage
was just too much for the wood
itself, and it popped it loose.
Your tang is a little bit small.
But what I do like to
see is that your blade
actually held up beautifully.
I mean, your grain
structure looks fine.
This is an absolutely
brutal test.
Very well done.
Thank you.
Now Dustin, you survived
every one of the strikes
except for the last one.
Your guard gave way and
your blade followed.
So we consider this a
catastrophic failure and cannot
continue testing your
blade, but you're not
out of the fight yet.
How are you feeling, Joshua?
Pressure's on.
All right.
So you need to survive five
strikes in order to be named
"forged in Fire" champion.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
All right.
Let's do it.
[sword striking]
[inaudible]
Well, Joshua, your
blade is strong.
It made it past all the strikes.
Congratulations.
Now Dustin, unfortunately for
you, that means your time here
in this competition has
ended because you did
have a catastrophic failure.
It was an honor watching
you in our forge,
but unfortunately,
man, at this time
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off our forge floor.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
I'm definitely crushed.
I actually thought that
recessing the sword
into the tang a little bit
would make it stronger,
and that's kind of
what bit me in the end.
So definitely, definitely,
won't be doing that again.
I'm definitely
proud of this blade.
I came here to challenge
myself as much as I could,
and I definitely achieved that.
Well, Joshua,
congratulations man.
That means you are the newest
"Forged in Fire" champion.
You just got yourself
a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
[applause]
Oo-ee!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
I made a sword
that didn't break.
Oh my gosh!
It was a hard competition,
so this was unreal.
Ahh!
[music playing]